[Music]
I'd like to talk with you return moment
which really give you a lot in visa the
times when not only your lot a lot of
game this is normal when you play a lot
of PS chess but you remember really the
games when you not only love the game
but you really felt pathetic ly I mean
you are a completely outplayed so there
may be a lot more of this game but I've
here tried to pick up like the most
important which I still remember some
details about them some of them I was
younger but still now they are very
important lesson because you learn a lot
about just from these painful losses so
the first one it was like yeah it was
probably the first Bulgarian
Championship which I played individual
for men I was 16 years old not so bad
but you see by this game that certain
kind of structures certain kind of ideas
were completely unknown to me so it
result in a very bad loss I cannot
comment it much about about this game
I'll show it to you but just to see it
ok basically white felt in every area
but mostly nurse to touch it concept
what they are doing in this type of
power structures so it was like Kings
Indian against a very talented
Grandmaster he's now not playing chess
for quite a few years maybe more than 10
but he was very talented very dynamic
player so he used to play a lot of
opening with his/her own ideas
Grandmaster down chief and he really had
a lot of energy and other talent for
chess so here he placed Knight bt7
to naturally go any place with a much
younger pawn which is still
inexperienced in a lot of pollution in
structures he tries to keep it like into
the more complex pawn structures this is
the King's Indian twin 1907 g6 now this
is more unpleasant than to play like the
old Indian with Bishop e7 because it
needs you know from white better
understanding so they are efficient with
Bishop ease
which would be to even probably this
edge I knew a bit about it but okay this
one with g6 not much about in now I'll
show you just from the first step it's
showing this during the the course of
the game so okay here we make the first
opening moves okay here of course you
have like a white choice probably now if
we play this patient although I cannot
experience much I can played much games
in this particular position the probably
I'll play with Bishop III and I am
familiar like let's say Bishop III just
show Bishop III like c6 of course not
the only move many maaske a possible d5
here 91 and if 91 you have the strategic
idea which comes from Kelvin also coming
paid with g4 of course this is this is a
very complex mission many players like
to play they even know some colleagues
which you know played quite skillfully
from the right side but here on Ricky
one which really is like this was like
the major theoretical move still
probably is one of them
but then you have to be known what
exactly is doing the draconian how you
should play the patient when you close
the pawn structure which you've seen
this game was completely unknown to me
what I was doing was in on many levels
wrong
so rookie won c-6 here basics well here
if you want to play a look and better
than to play not to close the same you
can play here route B 1 and B 4 probably
now I'll play something like that
because ok this type of pawns much I
never liked it so you have type of pore
structures which will enable although
now I know a lot more about it but still
I don't like to play this type of
project at least when I play closer
openings like in the latest 10 years at
least I try to play them without the
poem c4 not because it's better but
because I'm much more familiar then I
try to keep the rook on f1 1992-94
it's a little bit easier to open the
Queen side and also you know sometimes
you can combine it with f4 even to play
on on the on the King side here the
rookin iran in my opinion signifies that
you have to be prepared for some
prophylactic action against the possible
play on down the King side
so probably combine it with G
three and then if we place f5 to be
ready to to meet it with night h4 take
take Astro in this static past action
which obviously from the play now you
see it was quite unknown to me or maybe
I have heard but I was holed through the
whole course this game I was completely
not sure what I was doing and this
normally leads to two very heavy failure
so this was like a terrible game but you
learn you know what type of construction
you should work more but still even
today I'm not really happy to play this
type of structures never was very sure
maybe if you do more work on this type
of structures you can learn a lot from
the games of crumbling petrosyan earlier
which really just enjoy to play these
structures but I even today I'm you know
on a much lower level knowing so here a
three of course is not really an idiot
move you have to play a rootbeer one and
then be for all because you know to push
before you don't need III because okay
if he takes would be for after Rubin on
before you can make an old get his
Knight out of g5 and play Knight a for
him you know play on the queenside
we really a tree here in my opinion or
do it mainly because you'd like
something really violent egg it's not
needed so the first sign that you are
completely unsure what exactly we are
doing but it's not the only the only
sign 98 b4 h6 well at least black is
knowing exactly what he's doing
Hawk is going to try to play here on the
on the kingside that very standard play
to take five and okay he wants to show
how you meet that I stay prepared to me
that like I told you earlier like g3
Knight h4 and if I take take after all
so this is the good prophylactic moves
not the only one that is very standard
stuff now I know but in these days being
quite young and okay these were you know
different years of the development of
chess you didn't have too much
information you you had you I had a lot
of good chess books but still you know
you need to you can get so much
information in such short period of time
nowadays with the computers you can get
much much easier and you can see me at
the games of course I didn't expect it I
I don't remember so me
years ago but I didn't expect exactly
this kind of a opening scheme which was
a very wise a mature decision of
experience you know tournament player
which probably know that okay in this
type of and he was completely right
because like I told you earlier nowadays
I don't feel comfortable with this type
of clothes pawn structure especially
this one c-45 e4 c5 d6 track with the
bishop on jeater Naruto f5 tied b3 now
the whole maneuver 92-93 makes really
hard to put it mildly a set impression
because okay this note will not appear
on a5 if it does not appear on 85 what
is doing on b3 I mean really nothing so
it's a rather bad play and okay because
it's a rather bad play from a static
point of view it was punished very
severely how it should be punished
because you have to play with some idea
so 92 93 typically you know play without
any anything concrete so here of course
the next move is basics you know you not
let you undermine you know the c5 square
the knife is not going 25 so what what
was really in the whites hat is
difficult to say now b6 of course would
be one now like it only at least if you
want to play route Briony would have
played without a tree let's still 90 f6
okay his play is becoming too quite
obvious and now white start to panic
they should have played some other moves
I still like prefer the black patient
Bishop d3 it makes also a very bad
impression Bishop d3 f4 and okay now
he's coming with g5 you know g5 h I
don't know he's a tech now and you're
completely stuck yonder on the Queen set
you're completely stuck because you
didn't think think it over what you do
on the Queen side so basically he has a
clear-cut plan and you have nothing ste
yeah no because it does not make
anything you know in relation with what
black will play which would be three
justices move because sorry you plan to
play F for g5g for so are you doing
something about it how how you put your
cause basically nothing's for example
the Bishop II if in some way needs to be
in some place you remember from some
other life well maybe in some way
although here you elect put the [ __ ]
Pony tonight you want either to try
something to stop him on the on the
kingside but no I mean you continue to
play something else moves and now even
they miss like an f3 move well nobody is
winning but it's a rather obvious you
know choice here which for me diagram it
was surprised so f3 with a relative idea
if you take with a pool knight eh - is
start throttling on your on your black
squares well still I cannot say that
it's lost but from static appoint of you
to me atleast seems like a very bad
position because really just just
promotion what is really doing the
bishop on d3 I mean on f1 probably it
was better now g3 well now you are
getting even made it which is like a
nigera a very clear sign up at my
previous comment is the next move Bishop
f1 basically you absolutely lost what's
happening
h5 getting your may lead and and the end
was I also remember it quite well
because okay in this very bad position
from all points of view I mean
completely synthetic failure that's why
I quote you know this sour memory sly
static tail is because there obviously
that and they're not the only ones but
wait the most memorable was h3 I now
keep even place edge for no just giving
you mate
and okay why not to give mate if you
stand and wait for the for the open and
to come with his obvious plans this is
what happens natural you know take take
here you can't take it back because f2
know now some vain intense to stop he's
growing at a because he wants to take on
g4
way he has so many ideas he can even
transfer let me show you can even
transfer this look like lacking out or
even he can transfer it here because
okay what's happening here in 93 Bishop
d2
pathetic really but I play g5 here
that's trying to to get some square out
of this you know
but okay I mean he just plays Queen d7
and he was a part of this game which I
gave no resistance he was a very dynamic
and very good in in calculation and in
dynamics oh okay he doesn't need such a
bad play for me but okay I try to talk
help without wanting to do so
so Queen d7 now I take I try you know I
try to give up in exchange it leads to
stay in the game but no when you played
badly you know the you remember this
kind of punishment so check here now the
last move he does not want my rook you
just want to get me made with Queen h7
yeah so distress of the Queen is also
quite elegant not a difficult one
all right here of course I I think I had
enough it's quite obvious what follows
mate so it's something you remember so
this was the first final I played I even
won against two grandmasters okay one
grand master run I've missed a
completely winning position in a good
game but okay this was the game which I
really because I've lost quite a few
games there's no surprise but this one
was like complete you know I mean like
maybe I talked with some of you after
such a game if you're plating when I
started playing chess in the chest up in
my hometown if you lose a game like that
normally the phrase was well maybe you
should take a rest for like I and I have
you know just to study more and then
come back again because okay obviously
you're playing we were playing quite bad
so okay this was a rather memorable a
loss so we're getting like some years of
experience but still okay here I for
example here I gave 22 years but still a
man these were different times so you
couldn't get like seven nowadays you
know they get much quicker and they
learn much more about push and they gave
a lot more practice which is very
important you know you play but okay the
game was paid with a legendary still
alive I think they celebrate like 85 or
maybe more years of keep still alive
[ __ ] off why he is a legendary Russian
Grand Master in an ex Soviet of the USSR
Grandmaster because when Fischer came
with his sister to play blitz in Moscow
or he start dispatching of all the
players they sent he was okay they had
to
to form to the the best in a blitz
players in the in the Moscow so they
found a lotta cough now tell you a few
words about him and for the Zhukov which
were famous big players and also
Petrosian so there I go a little bit too
to stop official even duty cop says it
kick ass like a politics Kovacic off but
he's a very famous and a grandmaster he
was coach of many of the best he was
present I think also when Fischer played
one of the matches with whom when they
hit on June position and day yeah we
Taemin often in way he won six to zero
but also he wasn't pure it was the only
one he could make a draw but they missed
in the adjoint position I check mister
losing a rock so he was in the team okay
the very famous Grandmaster
but this game I remembered because he
okay let's let look it from the black
point of view because ok the guy made
work like a very standard for him for
his level exchange way for me it was
like something completely you know as a
surprise and ok after some years when
I've learned more about pitching now I
understand it's like a stand on two
exchanges but still it's a very good
lesson because you learn and it's not
like an exchange place when you lose no
it's not building pressure and he's just
better and you should just you know
watch out for this type of exchange
sacrifices because they are very
standard but for me it was a surprise so
yeah he plays like the Italian which
nowadays is like a new life because a
lot of incredible players like Carson
and are playing it they're giving it
like a more subtleties more a few more
position of details so ok it's a lot in
character like the real Lopez with a few
a few differences so we we've played
this line I forget experience in this
line well here to be honest the best
here you know just immediately ok this
is one of the of the important PCC in
this type of structure because the
knight on c6 is quite you know without
too much of a of a strategic future so
you want to put it very quickly you know
97 96 times because you know it feels
with with better options after that and
then of course not only that but you can
use you know the poor the poor on c6
sometime
even in different circumstances but very
similar hue Stephen an idea from the
Royal opus kramnik with black when the
night is moved he can even play on
Bishop III if you guys play tough before
that c6 Bishop b8 and then he's
defending the e5 pawn he can even push
d5 but the knight 27 is the correct idea
and okay on the line which was popular
here the right idea is this one to be
able you know to threaten age 16 if he
takes you take with that bomb on g6 one
of the exceptions of the basics that
accrue to takes towards the center
but here it's a much better because okay
it gives you you know good play on the F
line and okay you play Queen e7 Bishop
e6 there has been in games of an ant
with black alright this is like a normal
line for for black in my opinion they
don't have any real problems of course
it's not you know the only line for for
white but here I play to h6 not really
needed to a for Bishop e6 a5 rook e8 I'm
still sensible moves now nothing wrong
Bishop e3 well here in this kind of
signals you should be well when you
wanna push d5 because sometimes they can
build up pressure on the on the central
pawn like here one line I've given in my
odd comments on d5 well it actually if I
if you take you take on on e4 eventually
but if he takes here and start pressing
the pole you know it's not very easy to
if anything you don't want to part with
the with the LightSquared bishop because
then it will be present here you can see
the knight on c6 mainly has defensive
tasks and also that the pollen a Fife is
restricting you quite a bit the rookin
a7 not very well play so we'll need time
so I take Cooney tree but okay
this taken only three I played after
that quite a few games in the Italian in
on the recently I've played so this one
of the patient the Italian I have a lot
of experience so now there's much much
better but this game was very important
also to help in this so on e3 I don't
like the structure in a take honey tree
he takes and with the pawn because after
that it's quite clear what white is
going to do white is going to do
Quinny one night each for double Queen
g3 the double on the F line and okay
what you can do well most you can
passively defense or if you if you push
d5 you on GG spawn so he gets like quite
mobile and flexible pawn structure so
that's why only three now when I look at
all I prefer to take in the in the right
moment when Cain has played to donkey
one and if it takes me the Polsky has to
lose time which is one of the most
precious substances in chess this is
time and space so I know so I prefer a
key takes 187 I take now then then to
take only three in a not very fortunate
moment like one example here Mike these
are very old comments but I think that
they still should be quite good enough
because I've taken time I always thought
okay
okay you'd like a total he plays like
that and he starts building and pieces
and the most important thing which
nobody likes in chess you don't have
like a clear-cut plan he's piling up
pieces and okay and you have to defend
which is not like a very pleasant
feature so here I tried you know a
little bit late to transfer the knight
97 9 H 4 still you can notice it's a bit
late because of 96 key place Knight f5
and start you know still piling a piece
on the kingside still not in sight any
in any visible count to play but yeah I
thought okay I can play maybe b5 which
you know now from a synthetic point of
view looks quite suspicious but okay at
least I wanted to play something active
and it's missing completely
existing additional threat I repeat is
not winning you'll see but it's just
much easier to play with right and I
don't remember how much a hidden but not
not much for such an experienced
Grandmaster with a lot of you know
knowledge in and also not very good also
pleasure to kill Hughes mainly known for
very sharp tactical vision he has played
a lot of games with wheat out some of
them even famous one of them is
commanded in in the famous book of tau
in which tau you know in CARICOM he
takes Knight takes from g7 a very good
sacrifice and I was thinking a lot in
this
game is a famous game against Vasu cough
and he was thinking thinking like 40
minutes or more and okay when just to
tell you the racing when he started
thinking about this pigeon and you can
find very easily this game night g7 is
the movie was thinking the first 5 min
skills you know calculating life and Tao
was incredibly fast get greater but he
was a chess genius but incredible fast
things later but he understood that okay
the lines are piling up more and more he
took one line from the first line
another move and okay then quickly in a
pseudo array it's more about intuition
but all the other mean minutes he was
singing some song in his head from a kid
song and that's why he taught more than
40 minutes in the end okay he was fed up
with the witness also get away let's go
Eddie song you just have to sacrifice a
piece on g7 because this is like a
intuitive and he was very pleased when
the next day in the newspaper key right
at TAO after carefully thinking forty
moves and planning everything killer
sacrifice from g7 like a true genius ago
and this is what I like this a very good
so here after b5 he took and now he
makes a very standard like I put here
exchange sacrifice which I really care
to learn the hard way so Luke takes on
f6 take you Thank You Justin I learned
to this pigeon that you know when he
starts piling up pieces the nights are
really much more value of that look this
pork and this pork only ate well if they
can exchange pieces then maybe these
books can be valuable but not here Queen
h5 King g7 rook f1 even visually he has
like a very good compensation to say the
least
and it's very clear about what he'll
play in the next moves okay at least I
bring the rook here to make some
difference faction we have three
attacking my palm 96 well of course he
does not want exchanges 95 or if I have
to exchange I have to give him something
like for example if I take here probably
have taken with the palm and now he goes
here and all my life squares are you
know how I defend here
he has a root lift because of my b5 I
even this pawn is hanging sometimes on
d6 sometimes so basically his to like
pizza and much better than the night
only 7 the Poe night in the Roku nyet no
here if you give even this position to a
computer at first you say well maybe ok
maybe it's like this but then if you
move a little bit you on the Senate even
he can not find like something
satisfactory
I didn't paid here too badly I made one
mistake but ok the position in my
opinion is very is very difficult to
play here Bishop Zito
now you can exchange one of the night
but then you know some other points
eventually appear like here on d6
appears like a clear target and this
night can be transferred to no because
compared to you all night on Jesus which
is rather stupid because of the pawn on
entry
this Knight can go to 93 95 so basically
this night if we kept to be honest is
much better than the rook on h8 and ok
there are other obvious factors which we
can include and we even feel them we
don't have to look much much further we
feel that the differences of the priests
activity the difference of the of the
situation of the Kings well this makes
like in my opinion strategically
disliked already a lost position for for
black he is just trying you know to stay
in the game but should he should lose
and of course this Grandmaster kicked
out this quite you know in no time so
here I paid rookie 7 trying somehow ok
this mistake is easy toss and you try
some care with your products to get some
kind of square some kind of open lives
but ok I mean the end was quite near
here and our d6 now I've missed some
tactical detail as far as I as I
remember the tactical Adel that if I
took twice he just taken on f6 and then
I'm I'm tanking on on d5 no first time
can gain you know on g6 but if I play
something he plays d5 and there is like
a pin on my Queen on d6 no but still the
position in my opinion was very bad and
ok for such kind
a level in the play it was easy so okay
here I played age five out of
desperation probably take take ah no I I
want it like this move some kind of a
toy Quinn takes when I have six in here
I resigned because I mean I'm losing
everything in and the petition is not
getting better I mean none of my pieces
although I've given up some material
nothing is becoming like better here for
example let's take a look if I take on
f6 take and I oh yeah so there is small
detail probably provide me something
like a so here one I tell I'm seeing I
was looking at this let's see here
but check no yeah check well the polls
are coming are becoming less and less
now kick ass how much three and the
question is not getting better this is
the bad thing about synthetic failures
no I mean when you play with a good
player and you play something like that
such as the Italian normally this is
what what happens at the end and another
one which are you know which by chance
he was played like one year after this
one I played in growing again and there
was I remember siedler also a young a
young player you know he was incredibly
talented he played very fast and she's
so incredibly fast all kind of sacrifice
in this in okay I was quite impressed
now I was playing in the open and in one
world I it was in the night round how
are they doing so bad but I played also
with a very experienced Grandmaster
Russian rushkoff ski here's old in me he
was now after many times coach of the
national team in okay quite an
experienced player till they are some
some details about this game which I
still don't know now why we have some
opening choice after
c4g 6y play tonight is really for so
maybe I didn't want some kind of Bologna
with c5 but still I mean it's better
just because now I know much more I
don't know my state of mind in this year
I still was young but still I mean I get
knowledge strike if you want to
neutralize some kind of a some kind of a
opening lines you can play doubt that
and on c5 you can play a four or you've
got the morrow G or you got you know
Queen b6 or airline or you played 9c but
okay
still this is like a much better choice
because 93 Bishop g7 and now e4 just
promised this very rare line with d5
which even nowadays this line is quite
interesting if we have time maybe I can
show you a very recent game in which
black just remember one very fresh and
very good idea even cook with black
because he Machuca Speight almost any
opening you can imagine and not only
place them but he brings always very
fresh ideas so here after d4 here in 96
yeah one of the normal choice is just to
play Bishop e3 to hold on the center and
then on ninety seven ninety three let's
say d6 you have a choice the main
theoretical line is considered h4 right
but also you can play even take take or
if it takes with a bone then of course
let me show if you take with a pawn you
play Bishop Defoe this is the idea you
play Bishop Ito Castle castle Queen d2
you take when i5 from q1 it slightly
better white probably white is this
president has been played a lot so black
is kept in a very solid position but
here them the main contention which
immature brought and I saw a very recent
game in which black played very well in
the opening and they kept Australia
Convention but then ok in time travel
they lost him in the game you brought
this incredible idea Queen f6 which is
one of the many exceptions ok not so
many but quite a few settles when you
get early you know you develop early the
Queen and it makes sense because he did
pressures quite a lot I'll show you if
we get time in the end in this game of
course okay in this time I was up this
move was not even unknown in this years
but why I made this opening choice this
is like still a mystery for me now ok
Knight takes from c6
B takes on c6 93
d6 ok now the next move is a like really
bad so tragic mistake because it ok it
has like the right idea but you don't
have this luxury I mean you don't have
like an advantage in development just to
play a move chief
and to try to keep his bones like in a
bad shape so you should play Bishop d3
Casso depending if he goes 97 with c5 96
okay if it gives 96 you can cast on
Bishop g5 well I even remember one game
of course noise he played with be like
orange just developing the pieces but c5
he is terrible
just because it doesn't pay attention it
just develops increases okay if you want
to give me you know development
advantage be my guest
so c5 was typically impulsive in a very
stupid move and the punishment in this
game I remember quite quite well so
neither six of course now when when he
has like even a dungeon development you
prefer to develop your PC on the better
squares not only seven because you don't
have any more you know the doubled pawns
and then to played see five times
acknowledged or you won't in the most
active because development is not
problem for you anymore
I take take oh now you can play Bishop
a4 probably more ambitious I still think
that black has a good position okay
Bishop Ito in the same passive style you
know after c5 a knight f6 I I cannot
even
careful this idea what I have in mind
about the stupid move c5 so here Castle
castle and he starts playing in the most
natural fashion okie eight here every
one of his moves is very natural and are
very easy to find but still very
unpleasant you know we can have this
recollection also how cows in place now
now only eight first the rook needs to
open files here another temple move
Lukie 197 well here I was in a very bad
state of mind because okay we black page
so next row and he's getting off his
squares whenever he want now he's
threatening Bishop taken c3 and because
of this state of mind I was not able it
this year I was able to I was never like
great because in calculation like so
this wasn't it nevermind my fault but
still it was possible here to find like
the only way to to stay in the game but
ok I just calculated a few more and I
just didn't see the idea I guess I don't
remember
1990 but still I mean to find the only
way after 26 which six means to
sacrifice a piece with a temple I mean
it's very difficult you know when you've
played so badly in the opening normally
that's why we are completely different
than engine so we always have liked the
way we feel so we had like a bad history
and this is very very useful for chess
player because very very few chess
players have this ability I'll tell you
one example one just plays very famous
to this Karpov so carpet for example in
all of skeezius active when he played
chess one of his main features a lot of
it was this one
okay imagine you play with carpet so
five hours he's defending a slightly
worse position and you keep piling up
pressure he's defending his defending
very well because he was incredible good
like thousand in calculating precisely
where short lines like two three moves
never making even a second leg so he's
defending we're in one moment you a
little bit tired and you get taxi ok so
now it's an equal position okay now
we'll make a draw what can we do the guy
defended brilliantly many players like
nineteen more 10 will be quite happier
to this tough defense to get a draw but
no with Karpov the the the change of the
position that now it's an equal portion
didn't mean if he wanted no no he was
fresh as a cucumber now he begins to
play like a new game we didn't matter
the history of the game he suffered five
hours no he was ready to play five more
hours and to win and he won a lot of
games so this particular feature is very
difficult but ok very useful ok this
line to find Bishop c3 and now rook the
one threatening this Knight and also
including hidden hidden tactical motive
like if you defend it with this to kept
like this double attack well I mean give
me a break this never cross my mind
I mean this is like no no reason to make
so this was the only way to stay a
little bit in the game or if he moves
here let me show you if he moves the
rook to defend like that to have this
double attack attacking you know this
bishop and attacking the g3 well okay he
never crossed my mind and even this
disposition he has like Queen f6 when
I've checked it with a computer in the
peuta things that here black against
definitely nice but but here I think it
I have like good drawing chest yeah I
have a good chance you know to make like
a fortress I sacrifice the Queen and
head but nothing like that crossed my
mind so here I was completely you know
down feeling very bad after this better
opening up at this move
c5 I mean completely bad move I mean
only a bad back and like c5 and just
waste time and now okay the game
continued here it was difficult to find
really a sensible move because okay he
wants ninety five ninety three nights
for so I play Bishop a4 I saw rook takes
from Beto it was quite easy to see that
but I know that maybe the two bishops
can give me some sort of a drawing
chances look at the guy continued play
till the end with a normal precision
without giving chances so here this
patient I saw I thought poking Benny why
not you know you get some pause which
can be attacked
I had the pair Bishop which you know
here's the advantage is when you have a
pair Bishop always we can exchange one
of them so we can you know press the
pause and okay it seems like you have
decent drawing chances but he played how
chest should be paid actively a temple
again this should be five h3
now again of course natural move d5
using the pin against you Queen d2 d4
now you see the bishops are not very
active and the past pawn sorry a reality
so that the next part of the game was
just crushing here keeping his palm and
Bishop g4 you know very easy calculation
of course okay not difficult
precision till the end rook takes skill
and we take you
the queen is overloaded he can defend
the rookin can defend d2 if Queen C 1 D
don't know
so ok here it was time for at least I
should have played this probably this is
losing here but it gives at least some
you know some practical chances like
here Queen a for how
he has to Paul but I some chances I
played like some kind of a kamikaze
style he queen it for Quincy three here
Bishop d6 laughs I mean you're really
not threatening anything special and it
with good players you can't give them a
lot of scare he was he was not having a
time shark you're scaring like a bit
sure the time but nothing special any
okay he played like very god Carla here
and now the idea is it okay basically if
you look like that maybe you can imagine
you can dream it to you're threatening
something but with a very simple moves
the guy played just here a try for now
if you take I place as Queen g7 and the
reality is what's on the board the
reality that he's going to kept another
another queen and okay you are just
playing some kind of a stupid position
in which you should have resigned which
happened after here Queen g1 check and I
resigned here
now these failures were quite you know
quite painful but okay you try to learn
from them so just to show you in this
position what was the idea before going
to some a little bit more so it I've
encountered this a game from the 2018
so the same position with a different
more order just to show you that the
idea of even took Queen f6 a very
ancient and the main idea is now you
take with a deep own because it helps
your development okay this is like a
rather creative opening idea although
okay just just just to know that there
is such a such a line with with Queen f6
quite interesting so let me give you one
one really good satanic example by the
best in now in the the world
magnification because okay he played
also with a very strong in a very strong
opponent it was like one year ago it was
about position which today I saw an
example that that remind me this game so
I was watching like a lecture ferry
crossing about this game let me just saw
the position so I was watching that he
played
Fedora which was inducted in in the USA
chess Hall of Fame and they played this
line okay just let me so and this remind
me that I saw a brilliant game which of
course was a an opening idea which was
probably very well analyzed by the team
of Carson so I saw this game in this the
Queen's Gambit exchange and after III am
Bishop at five do know here what is the
the main line for white why you can get
so easily with Bishop a5 and ninety
seven yeah Queen f3 is the main line and
this is the game I'll show you between
Carson and comic because kramnik has
played this line with white but also of
that because he has a tendency of study
very well very complex and games
he tried against cars in this line but
Carson came very well prepared well in
this game which I saw the day Fedora
which was seen as some kind of a
hooligan move so he played like that
page three and then lost in sixteen
moves with white but okay it's not it's
not necessary so let's see one of the
who maybe will become one of the best in
the in the Chesky story how he does it
here so lets me find this game of
because I also found the key played
after that another game yeah this is the
one recently online so he paid two
thousand another another guy in this pro
league he played the gearcase at the
same position
so even when I saw this game with with
chronic it was obvious that this
position was analyzed but but his team
and he had a a very good idea probably
his idea but chronic this was not the
first game of chronic in this in this
opening line so let's take a look to see
a very good so Tajik play by by Carson
in Italy Bishop f5 and okay this end
game can be playing a lot and until this
game they white get tried various ideas
so okay in this endgame let's try like
g3 Bishop Bishop h3 and then to go
Knight f3 Knight h4 but then whatever
they played was 97 96 Bishop
to be fought we exchanged in the night
ghosts 94-96 and I hold the v square and
okay you are better but here not not
it's not a question whether white is
better it's a question can they go
further you know to get like a real
advantage
so here the main idea which Carson this
great player found was night h4 and now
he's trying to play in a very special
way against this Bishop on g6 okay here
he played Bishop e7 you see just the
first theoretical novelty but when he
after death he played with a knob I I
don't know this game probably
international master Sheriff EF online
in 2017 so let me first show you this
game quickly so he played Knight b6 and
now in this game
he showed some other aspect of this
Knight age four idea so now with f4
because the bishop is not on e7 now so
he closes this Bishop Bishop d3 so
immediately the f5 pawn is hanging only
move now let me just show because of a
no other way to to defend the pawn on f5
no because he didn't pay Bishop e7 like
Kramnik did which guess like which is
the special idea of white so now Knight
c4 but now I take it and very
importantly tell the King on F to the
King on f2 defense brilliantly spawn and
immediately makes way of the rooks and
the rooks
gets into play and the bishop on g6 can
go into play but the most we can can get
and to be exchanged for one of the night
like night night one age for you know he
gets exchanged the King is even better
in the center like imagine it on f3 and
the poles are still and white and two of
them are doubled which means that I have
night against your bishop and it means
that many of your pawns can be
vulnerable because who defend them if
you don't exchange your bishop you have
to play the whole game with the bishop
on g6 so here obviously from the
starting point of this pigeon is clear
that what Rafi has played in this online
game one year after this game is
completely
strategic fiasco no any kind of end game
is bad so he just played very natural
moves now if you take here I just take
with the rook and then the room goes to
d5 they start collecting pause
like so he played Bishop e7 now I go to
f3 and the best you can do is to
exchange you know your Bishop for my
knight but they still leaves the
question what about your pawns these
like a static ball structured the knight
is much more versatile now he played 95
even this so notice how how good is the
King on f2 always depending on the pawn
on only 3 this also in my opinion was
very bad but ok I mean the world
champion knows better now he opens the
game but of course ok you have problems
with coordinating your pieces and the
rest of the game was just pure
demonstration of the complete dominance
of the of the white position just very
quickly just to show you but ok this was
like toying with him no the night goes
in like I told him nobody can defend the
pawn so he starts collecting them one by
one here now he has a clear path poem
well he like I thought it's like a
static pawn structure so the bishop is
just you know nothing compared to the to
the knight no rule d5 and he collected
everything let's look at this important
game without ok it's very rare that a
player of the caliber of Kramnik which
analyzes his end games like the Berlin
game very very profoundly he gets
straight out of the opening in a
complete strategic strategically lost
position so that's why I when I watched
today this game of Rawson with fedora
with Roger I remembered this one because
this one was incredibly made a a very
long lasting impression to me so he
played Bishop e7 here and now the new
idea 92 so he tries in a special way to
control the f5 Square how he tries to
control it he was 93
but here the main important issue of
this whole idea is when you don't have
any piece key on on the queenside
can you withstand some action of the
black key on the on the on the queenside
here he played Knight b6 immediately
trying to challenge tactically the
strategic idea of white which where it
was needed
- beforehand to have like a good
knowledge and okay
Carson not only can start kicad like
incredible memory so he remembers online
very very well here
he plays Bishop h5 you can a couple of
idea
you can play h3 you can play f4 trying
to keep it static of course one thing
you should never play now this thing
there is no words more than this move
why because he can check me anything one
no visual before well Carson wouldn't
get played hi can I show you because ok
but all right here like a dog fo looks
quite interesting also h-street
looks interesting but he played the most
probably studied by the team of Carson
I'd be 1696
you know wants exactly that and he is
very important how is this pigeon of 93
of course you've got like a prominent
idea to put something on f5 which is
like taking firm control a very
important square and still leading with
weak bones so one of the ideas if you
play like that like night a4 immediately
I just Castle you know Castle and I put
an item a5 no this is like a clear
advantage no not not visible any any
counter play that's why the important
thing at this Bishop b4 here because
okay it leaves your King without casting
here king D 1 and now probably he went
in some line which was analyzed by my
cousin his team Knight e4 which the
tactical mistake but it cables when they
play or very interesting new idea and
you have to cope with all over the broad
94 probably better but still this
position after 95 or at least this is
what I have looked Castle King Seto hear
it it looked to me like a first line
this one Bishop d3 when I looked at it
still you know seem some Pleasant for
example this kind of endgame also seems
unpleasant because with the even with
the opposite Kyle bishop you have a lot
of weak pawns and I can transfer my my
pieces I have nice cute could be a
torture against against the Carson or if
you don't exchange in play here I can
try to
- first like a end game with a with a
better night against the against the
bishop now fills up our play h3 and now
try you know I don't know how much you
can withstand you know this pressure on
g6 and I have you know some plans to
make my position better in my opinion
all 94 I can play rook x1 still not
clear you know what what they'll play
after that but 94 was a mistake based on
some kind of miscalculation which
probably Carson knew beforehand oh if he
does Mookie so on the broad 95 a very
unpleasant move because now it in turns
out that you really are not not
threatening on Beto let's just look at
this line so if you take on b2 I played
here it's a very important detail here
that if you play 94 I come here with a
double attack with the king which is not
like you know very common here and you
lose two for one
so rook for two pieces which would be
very easy loss and if you play here I
can take entrance from the patient room
b1 and now you're hanging on pizza in
still you are left with a very you know
not not so good bishops to put it mildly
and I'm left with a very powerful nights
and okay the rooks are very very active
so he played here King this heaven after
this strong move but okay
now as if you are the whole your opening
concept was a you know a failure because
okay now I got the square five and I
throw away all your pieces okay the rest
was simply like punishing punishing
karmic focus tragic failure let's see
now because it's like a very easy play
for 4000 C 592 you know with one square
week like when he five which means that
the pawns will be always weak so there
is no way out now you see now he's
threatening Knight f4 know and now you
also have so the first active move you
do and because of the weak to 0 square
they are piling up the witness now he
applies 92 in our ketones night for
techno and there is nobody god
the d5 bomb he took here I took with a
poem now i've wrote in my lectures in
terrible time trouble now but it does
not make things easier
so Bishop d6 at least he is trying to
keep you out of fo know this check but
now comes h4 now he wants h5 to play so
it was a complete failure for for
kramnik which is not known for having so
much failure h5 oh yeah I mean the other
option is just to play here to permit
here to play h5 so this patient also
does not inspire much much of a
happiness no h5 which of course gives up
material check take on h5 now you still
have died 5 square week and I have like
passport on day 12 and if I something a
person would hit there is another one
and other soldier coming so you see he
doesn't give him like a single chance
and now of course I still have two
nights in a static position like a bones
I have a past age Pole and you have
nothing for it I mean he has given him
anything so the rest was just you know
purely you know torture for Kramnik h6
b-tree just in case you know just
nothing that you have any square he
takes away even the chief of square 93 I
don't know why he didn't retire because
like it was like a pure torture
take Bishop a4 but still you know in
this patient it's good not to give any
counter changes to finish him you know
well just not to to have any illusions
rook c5 the pawn on d5 is screaming here
check hello ok he dances a little bit
with the Knights no ok
he can make this dance because always
the FI square the weak square because
normally when you have weak squares this
is a very good example when you have
weak squares it's not mean only to cap
the pause a week it means the the
squares in front of them a week and we
have a typical example here now he
always you know when I fight so you can
even touch the pollenate secret because
95 check and ok it becomes like
embarrassing well now you see because
yes so many weak bones gives even happy
give them to get some square at least
you know you know to have something to
live for
but away it does not make life easier
because he says picked up one at the
pole and we had the same pleasure so
give me more
here you can very hardly you can look a
lot of games are coming but it's
difficult to find such a hopeless loss
of him
what ok that's why we have such a
incredible world champion now he
exchanges one of your pieces ok it's
becoming like he had a pigeon a job
because ok almost impossible to stop the
poem so you have to deploy one of your
own eyes but only mission to stop the
poem 95 forcing up a rather plane a
10-game age 5 making fun of him all
right here everything wins but ok h5 is
like that the mall the mercy let's move
now a 7 is threatening you don't get
night night g6 just in case hello ok
well he continued here to play but ok
here he told it maybe it's it's time to
to resign but he ok from from the loss
of chronic which is an incredible teller
one of the best in the this one stands
out like a real satanic beating but ok
it helped it probably died he brought on
this patient but but how the game
proceeded after like the opening phase
in which he came out with a very bad
static position because his tactical
intent to get some counter on the
queenside probably was analyzed before
can and he machine configuration after
that the beating was very very severe ok
sometimes when you play with this chair
Genesis this is what you get
so this for today I tried to share with
you some of my failures and also to show
some of the the easiness will teach the
best in the chess world like Carson does
it almost always so we will try to get
better by looking at this good example
so thank you for today and see you soon
[Music]
you
[Music]